alors comment qualifier je suis tailleur
de pierre sculpteur graveur ornemaniste
j'ai sculpté évidemment beaucoup de
steve de monuments funéraires dont je
voulais trouver un terme général à tout
ça et je me suis alors est ce que c est
ce qui m'appartient le terme je sais pas
j'ai voulu me qualifier depierreux tout
simplement parce que je trouvais que ça
regrouper tout l'ensemble de mon travail
je me suis dit voilà d'un amoureux de ta
matière mais maintenant on l'a tué un
pied re fait lui honneur on peut voir
sur cette photo une carrière et j'ai
l'impression d'être d'être fait de
s'être fait de laver des trophées de
matières brutes qu'on peut on peut s'en
apercevoir on se rend compte à travers à
travers cette matière toute la force qui
a eu l'heur découler et c'est vrai que
c'est une matière vivante depuis le
xiième siècle en auvergne tout
particulièrement à volvic
les gens ont façonné la lave de cette
façon à pouvoir construire les
cathédrales pouvoir construire nos
maisons construire aussi nos monuments
vous avez l'art funéraire
jusque dans les années 80 c'était
principalement le business à volvic
voilà donc une vierge de sculpter qui
avait été fait dans les années 40
et puis voilà moi lama vierge à moi donc
ça c'est une sculpture que j'ai que j'ai
sculpté à l'âge de 13 ans donc je vous
cache pas que quand je le regarde
maintenant elle est là d'être un petit
peu grossier son nez enfin leur besoin
d'un bon lifting
mais bon c'était ma première pièce et
pourquoi j'avais sculpté ça parce qu'à
l'époque à l'atelier évidemment on
culte et que de l'art funéraire et
j'avais vu mon père grand-père scouts et
des têtes de crise des vierges en fait
tout ce qui a amené justement la finir
simplement pour vous dire que je suis
fils petit fils et arrière petit fils de
tailleur pierre sculpteur et c'est vrai
que je sculpte la pierre depuis l'âge de
10 ans je ne savais pas si je savais
faire du domaine du vélo avant mais
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours traîner un
petit peu dans les guêtres de mon père
et voilà le résultat donc juste pour
l'anecdote pour la photo on nous a
demandé de poser
évidemment on a posé mais en fait c'est
juste avant qu'ils prennent la photo on
s'était mis tous les deux en position et
m'en faire mon père m'a même pas
regarder vous dire voilà qu'on était
vraiment perry fils était vraiment dans
les gènes de croiser le fer là on a
voulu amener un peu de sensualité à
travers notre atelier karine justement
qui nous accompagnent dans notre atelier
et qui a créé justement une objets de
décoration qu'on appelle le cube
et là évidemment voilà mes compagnons
donc je suis accompagnée d'une de ses
compagnes ont tous des gens assez
extraordinaire des gens passionnés que
j'ai enfin qu'ils vivent au quotidien
avec moi et il est clair que ce sont les
enfin ces personnes on son petit peu le
prolongement mes idées à travers leurs
mains évidemment quand on travaille sur
des pièces monumentales je veux pas tous
fabriqués et c'est eux qui qui exécute
mais est pure qui travaillent qui
exécutent tout mon travail que j'ai
dessiné en amont en 1998 alors que je
débutais un petit peu dans la sculpture
je sortais mon école des beaux-arts un
une entreprise clermontoise qui fabrique
des pneus était en train de restaurer
son 100 sièges et ils m'ont demandé de
sculpter un bibendum
alors évidemment je voulais pas
m'attaquer à la figurine qu'on connaît
un et je m'étais dit ah bon pourquoi pas
essayer de faire un bibendum à la
thierry courtadon donc c'est pour ça que
j'avais voulu déjà raconté l'histoire du
bibendum
à travers cette page de dentelle et
surtout sculpter le bibendum de cette
façon avec akli d toujours la première
petit timide et de l'image du bibendum
quitté à cet empilement de tout petits
pneus
donc quand on travaille sur une pièce
monumentale de ce type
entre en amont on travaille toujours sur
une maquette donc c'est une maquette à
l'échelle 1 5e lors déjà règne sur la
maquette on a déjà montré l'entourent
deux mois de travail
non je vous cache pas qu'on compte pas
les heures il arrive maintenant quand on
travaille nous dans notre dans l'échelle
de temps d'un tailleur pierre d'un
sculpteur on travaille surtout avec les
jours les mois et parfois les années
donc là deux mois de travail pour cette
sculpture est ensuite sur la pièce
monumentale qui fait environ trois
mètres de haut on était environ sur dix
mois de travail et là sur ce texte qui
est assez énigmatique et pragmatique qui
vraiment quelque chose de grave et et le
pragmatique bibendum qui a retenu
l'enseignement du destin tragique de ses
confrères tout ça pour raconter qu'en
fait cette figurine elle avait traversé
le siècle elle s'était composée de
toutes sortes d'éléments et qu'au xxième
siècle elle était en pierre et qu'elle
avait toujours su rebondir et on avait
toujours évidemment ce mouvement et se
bibendum qui passait à travers cette
page d'histoire et j'avais voulu
traduire aussi que cette pièce est situé
à côté d'une petite rivière sur dans
l'enceinte des carmes à l'épicentre et
d'un côté on allait en avait les
ateliers et d'un côté on avait les cols
blancs les gens qui réfléchissent et
j'ai voulu montrer en fait que le
travail intellectuel ne pouvait
s'effectuer sans ses cols bleus et
c'était cette voie là c'est un petit peu
cette image et j'étais très fier à cette
époque je me souviens d'anecdotes de
gens qui venaient qui venait des
ateliers qui avait jamais l'habitude de
traverser ce fameux pont pour venir du
côté des cols blancs et ce jour là le
jour la sculpture était mise ils sont
venus voir et sont rendus compte que
d'un mec comme eux un mec qui avait
simplement demain et qui travaillait
avec ses mains et est capable justement
de provoquer une émotion
donc il ya eu toutes sortes d'anecdotes
tiennent évidemment une anecdote un
petit peu plus triste je veux pas vous
cacher dit c'est que le jour du décès du
gérant de cette fameuse d'entreprise il
avait plu énormément et donc cette
sculpture et position à ce socle et
quelques jours après il ya eu une suite
mans d'eau qui est qui tombait à travers
ce socle et il s'était dit on m'avait
raconté qu'en fait la sculpture pleurer
cette personne et c'est vrai que c'était
assez émouvant c'est touchant sa à
savoir que cette personne si
était venu à l'atelier pour me voir
cette sculpture pour cette maquette elle
avait été dans son bureau et voilà
c'était peut-être aussi un petit peu son
bébé que voilà l'anecdote c'est triste
alors là une petite évolution un petit
peu dans notre travail c'est à dire que
c'est vrai qu'on est des pierreux on a
fait des pierres tombales des stèles on
a créé des monuments et là une grande
marque de voiture nous a demandé de
créer un sofa et là c'était très
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'en fait avec la haute
technologie et puis avec des produits
contemporains tels que le carbone on
pouvait faire une belle objectivité avec
la matière brute et le carbone
donc ça c'est un sofa donc moi je
franchement je vais essayer c'est pas
hyper confortable c'est pas mais bon
techniquement c'est enfin on était
vraiment fier parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que la matière brute hoyé avec
les filages du carbone et en finlande et
au premier on avait une belle
objectivité une belle transition entre
ces deux matières donc cette pièce a été
exposée au salon du design à milan et
ensuite elle est partie à pékin et là
elle est allée dans le showroom de le de
cette marque de voiture sur les champs
elysées donc on est un petit peu fier
parce que techniquement ça demandé
énormément de travail
le carbone rentrer dans la pierre et
c'était tout un travail manuel n'y avait
pas de travail numérique donc c'était
assez compliqué alors là ça c'est mon
coup de coeur et sans faire de jeu de
mots c'est à dire j'avais voulu un peu
évoqué simplement à travers ma pierre à
travers la matière ce que je ressentais
comme peut-être vous aussi chaque fois
je crois je reviens de paris où chaque
fois je reviens de lyon quand vous
arrivez en vo de sept buts et que vous
voyez votre volcan et vous vous dites ça
y est je suis chez moi et en fait ce que
j'avais voulu kg voulu sculpter un
électrocardiogramme et évidemment à un
moment précis de l'électrocardiogramme
vous avez le battement du coeur
donc voilà tout simplement c'était bon
il n'y a pas de discours intellectuel je
suis navré mais c'était vraiment ce que
je ressens et j'espère que vous aussi
vous ressentez chaque fois que vous
arrivez à un roe de sept buts et
gouaille ça y est je suis arrivée chez
moi
j'ai pas si vous la reconnaissez parce
qu'en fait la signature c'est une
empreinte digitale
donc on au 21ème siècle est maintenant
évident même nous pierreux à la gare de
volvic on travaille avec le avec le
numérique et on s'est rendu compte qu
évidemment au niveau du travail du
dessin et au niveau du travail de
l'élaboration de certaines pierres au
niveau du façonnage on était capable
d'aller dans une forte précision et là
c'est une échelle c'est une empreinte
digitale à l'échelle 1
c'est à dire qu'on nous sommes arrivés à
sculpter sur trois dixièmes de
millimètre la vraie mais la vraie est la
vraie emprunte alors pourquoi j'ai
pourquoi j'avais voulu exprimer et faire
ce travail parce que je me suis rendu
compte déjà de la technique qui avançait
et que maintenant j'étais capable et je
me suis rendu compte que mon grand père
qui dans les dents avec qui j'avais je
vous cache pas traîner dans l'atelier
jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans puisqu'il a si
le disparu j'avais cet âge ils n'avaient
jamais vu mon travail et c'est même peut
évidemment la frustration de ne pas
avoir vu mon travail de maintenant si tu
avais son empreinte digitale sculpté sur
un élément en pierre je pense que ça
serait ton d'objets de plus précieux
donc voilà pourquoi j'ai eu cette idée
je demande de scouts et ça parce que je
me suis dit c'est ça sa vraie identité
toute sa vie il va travailler avec ses
mains et c'était pas on n'était pas dans
un contexte en plus morbide et je
trouvais ça très esthétique et à travers
ça je veux raconter vraiment l'histoire
d'une famille de notre famille ekwalla
qu'en fait on laisse une trace peut-être
un autre image mais voilà qu'elle est
faite pour l'éternité
alors encore là une prouesse technique
mais là plutôt au niveau de la
lévitation donc voilà on s'essaye à tous
donc je vous cache pas que quand on
conçoit une sculpture une maquette on et
nos limites c'est à dire on conçoit on
fabrique notre maquette à l'échelle 1 5e
donc c'est de la rigolade
évidemment parce que les pois les
dimensions des pierres elles nous sont
elles sont elles nous sont réservés et
puis elles nous sont accessibles mais
bon je ne pense jamais question parce
que je me dis on est au 21ème siècle
et quoi qu'il arrive on trouvera la
solution je suis pas tout seul on va
m'aider il ya peut-être des gens des
ingénieurs qui m'aideront pour les
suspensions donc là un exemple concret
de sculptures qui à l'échelle 1 7e et
qui mesurent 7 mètres de haut qui fait
environ 45 tonnes donc on voit là on
voit la sculpture sur
un monumental est une sculpture qui
devant un centre commercial et la
personne n'avait demandé de rendre un
hommage au fondateur de sept de ses
magasins justement de c'était des gens
passionnés par les livres à jeudi alors
qu'est ce que je peux bien lui raconter
à travers une sculpture et jeu mais
j'avais pensé justement à tordre la
matière à tordre la pierre est en fait
voilà j'ai pas tordu la pierre que l'on
peut tordre un morceau de ferraille avec
trois coup de chalumeau et des tirs au
détour et la matière non là on est parti
d'un bloc massif et on a sculpté dans la
masse non sur cette sculpture j'ai gravé
mais je me souviens à l'époque neuf
mille lettres
c'est à peu près un an de travail et à
savoir que chaque fois quand tu vois là
on voit un peu plus de détails chaque
fois qu on sculpte une pièce il suffit
de tomber sa massette pour entendre son
ciseau la pièce elle est morte donc
évidemment c'est tout le risque et c'est
ce qui fait évidemment tout l'intérêt de
la pièce parce qu'il n'ya jamais rien
d'acquis
jusqu'à la pause la moindre erreur est
bon imaginez la frustration et ça m'est
déjà arrivé je leur racontais ya pas
tellement longtemps
ou justement j'ai une pièce qui que
j'avais fabriqué pendant trois mois et
je me suis retourné je me suis entravé
dans le très tôt et puis elle est tombée
dans un esprit zen je vous dis je l' ai
rêvé te sens je me retournais la pièce
elle sera sur ses tréteaux c'est pas
possible
non c'est pas possible ça ne peux pas
j'ai fait un cauchemar et puis ça va
vite
je me retourne évidemment elle était par
terre il est en mille morceaux donc
complique évidemment sur coup je suis
allé courir 20 minutes déjà sa came un
petit peu les esprits et au quotidien de
cette fameuse culture donc j'ai récupéré
les bribes de cette dentelle et je dis
bon qu'est ce que je vais en faire je
les mets dans ma brouette les emmènent
dans le tas de déchets je vais réfléchir
on verra on va pas le faire tout de
suite on peut peut-être avoir des
remords et des regrets
et hier justement mallet une personne
qui est passée cette sculpture on dirait
la planisphère c'est super beau et là je
me suis dit ça a marché en fait ce que
j'ai pu j'ai récupéré toutes mes dents
tel jésus empilées les unes sur les
autres sur une vue trois dimensions et
c'est devenu une sculpture évidemment je
suis fier des sculptures je raconte pas
l'histoire à tout le monde mais bon
voilà encore une petite mésaventure mais
tout ça pour dire quand même qu'il une
telle frustration qu'on al'impression
travail est un matériau qui est
indestructible
son point de fusion c'est 1000 de 180° c
de la pierre on imagine évidemment que
et non en fait
nous on veut tellement aller loin dans
sa fragilité dans sa torsion dans son
mouvement qu'en fait on prend énormément
de risques
évidemment on essaie de la transcender
en fait et ben voilà
le risque c'est ça
une maquette à l'échelle 1 5e d'une
sculpture qui est dans une mairie où la
mairesse m'avait demandé de raconter un
petit peu l'histoire de sa commune et je
me souviens d'anecdotes et la veille de
présenter le projet jeunes n'avaient
absolument rien fait j'étais malade
comme un chien j'avais absolument rien
fait mais qu'est ce que je vais lui
faire je me suis retrouvé en face de
deux feuilles de papier pour les afin de
dessiner la sculpture ayant fait pas
d'idées pas de dessin j'ai pris les
feuilles de papier gt tour du jeu de
tête donc le lendemain tout penaud
j'arrive vers ma cliente et je dis bon
ben je vais vous faire ça je vais d'ordu
ces deux feuilles de papier devant mener
judy rassurez vous dans un mois je
reviens avec la maquette
donc voilà le résultat en fait ce sont
deux pièces que j'ai vraiment tordu et
qui se sent qui s'entrelacent
d'un point de vue technique pour vous
dire jusqu'au moment où jusqu'où on peut
aller dans la frustration c'est le poids
des pièces au départ de ces deux
feuilles de poids de les pièces de
départ faisait on se donne donc un
volume quand même à maîtriser assez
compliqué pour nous ce sont des blocs en
plus j'étais fier mais vous pouvez pas
savoir c'était des blocs que mon
grand-père avait stocké depuis 50 ans et
comme une carrière qu'on a vu au départ
une carrière c'est quand même un bloc de
sucre tout fragmenté une ctc j'ai dit
bon ben c'est blanc qui vont servir à ça
donc j'étais fier que mon grand-père et
préserver ses morceaux de pierres parce
qu'évidemment sur des volumes capable de
cette dimension c'est extrêmement rare
et j'ai sorti ces deux feuilles donc 11
tonnes je me perds et ensuite la pièce
galve est évident et en dentelle la
pièce des pubs 600 kg et enfin donc pour
dire qu'ils avaient plus de dix tonnes
de pierres qui sont partis à la benne
quand je vous racontais tout à l'heure
que la simplicité de faire une maquette
là ça a été exactement le principe est à
dire nous voilà partir de faire notre
sphère 60 cm avec des éléments comme ça
on a collé notre pièce est ensuite après
on a façonné notre sphère bon de la
rigolade et puis et le client super
content j'avais créé des entretoises
d'un lac ce qu'on s'en rende compte
mais le jour où il a fallu fabriquer
évidemment la monumental à savoir qu un
monumental elle pèse 40 tonnes est
évidemment dans une carrière au niveau
des volumes de pierre on n'a pas des
diamètres de trois mètres dans ce lieu
que je colle justement par cas
évidemment chaque élément est évidemment
les soucis là ont commencé parce que on
n'arrivait pas à trouver les bonnes
résine on n'arrivait pas à trouver les
bons goûts jonage chaque fois qu'on
soulever une pièce on cas
c est en plus à savoir que chaque pièce
est évidemment avec son endroit précis
on avait exactement le diamètre précis
et la courbe de façon à ce qu'à la fin
quand on les empile on est une courbe
parfaite et là je vous cache pas pour
une des premières fois j'ai failli
baisser les bras parce que ça a été très
compliqué très compliqué et bombe à
force d'obstination et puis bon on a dit
on va quand même pas se laisser avoir
on est on est arrivé et ça a marché
simplement au niveau d'équilibré aussi
comme quoi on est quand même des
tailleurs de pierre et on travaille
parfois millième de millimètre
la première pièce qui soutient la sphère
mesure 45 cm de diamètre sur 2 cm
d'épaisseur à dire qu'au niveau de l'
équilibre de cette pièce si on avait
fait la moindre erreur de quelques
millièmes la sphère est ce la faire
rouler alors là c'était pas bon signe
en fait j'ai un souci c'est que le souci
que j'ai c'est que j'aurai jamais le
temps de tout faire c'est vraiment je
vous cache pas que on est tous stressés
par quelque chose et moi c'est le seul
souci que j'essaie de me dire mais j'en
ai tellement dans la tête et j aime
danser ni père activité vous en rendez
compte
et je me dis mais comment je vais faire
et j'ai dit on our est une île siècle et
c'est vrai qu'on travaille le métal et
le bois car même d'une façon numérique
j'ai dit bon je m'intéressais à ça et là
voilà j'ai découvert un outil assez
extraordinaire le travail numérique
alors pourquoi elle va me permettre
d'acheter du temps elle va me permettre
de pouvoir ébaucher des pièces et ce
surtout qu' il ya quelques mois je vous
ai montré mon compagnon je vous et
montrez moi j'étais capable de réaliser
tout ce que je pensais alors j'étais
déjà fiers de réaliser tout ce que je
pensais mais maintenant je suis capable
de réaliser tout ce que je rêve
voilà la différence et ça voilà un
exemple concret voilà une pièce d'une
espèce de ressorts monumentale et bain
une pièce comme ça simplement programme
n'est de l'objectivité ses 150 heures de
travail à la main et la c8 heures à la
machine évidemment ça n'enlève rien à la
créativité parce qu'il faut toujours
créer la pièce vaut l'avoir imaginé mais
cette pièce je l'avais imaginé il ya
vingt ans elle était dans un petit coin
de mon afin de de mes croquis mais
jamais j'avais osé parce qu'évidemment
je n'ai pas le temps donc voilà
l'intérêt tout ça et là on a encore une
pièce voilà un détourage sur des
tableaux baroques encore assez simple on
a fait encore quelques exemples
voilà on travaille sur des objets très
design très contemporain donc une
nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
une nouvelle approche un petit peu de
mon travail c'est que j'ai toujours
exposé en intérieur et c'est vrai
j'avais envie de travailler un petit peu
avec les éléments et je me suis rendu
compte que c'est vrai que la nature
matière et j'avais envie de travailler
avec la matière et avec avec les arbres
avec la nature donc j'ai voulu créer
quelques oeuvres un petit peu landa et
voilà donc une pièce quand je vous
parlais tout à l'heure des dix des onze
tonnes d'éclats des 10 tonnes d'éclats
ou là ce que j'en fais après donc voyez
tout part pas à la ben j'arrive à les
allées calpine et et a créé v a créé
justement des oeuvres où j'essaie
justement créé une oeuvre en aller en
lévitation
ça c'est ma dernière pièce que j'ai
effectué leurs dentelles donc si huit
mois de travail pour une pièce comme ça
simplement vous dire que puis je suis
gamin avec mon père quand on prend des
pierres tous les deux des pires pay pay
ce qu on a toujours vu un petit cintrage
on sait dire je me suis dit tiens c'est
marrant la pierre quand même et à un
certain mouvement et j'ai voulu traduire
un jour en me disant bon ben qu'est-ce
qui pourrait plus retransmettre la
torsion et le mouvement et ben voila
j'ai dit je vais essayer de faire leur
sort alors vous cache pas j'en ai fait
plusieurs quand même pas mal mais voila
voila le résultat
donc évidemment je vais pas vous laisser
essayer parce que je vous connais vous
allez l'impression que c'est du métal
vous allez me casser mais tout ça pour
se rendre compte que quand même on
arrive à avoir un certain mouvement
voyez on a une amplitude amis d'un
centimètre et demi et c'est vrai que ben
on voudrait tous jeté un moellon par
terre et c'est vrai que vous l'avez
jamais vu rebondir et c'est vrai que se
rendre compte que la pierre soit
flexible enfin au delà bhl au delà de
l'esthétique j'ai surtout une émotion
qui sont beaucoup roulent à la pierre
voilà elle peut être pas forcément figée
elle peut être en mouvement
voilà je suis un père heureux je suis
fils petit fils et arrière petit fils de
tailleur de pierre que j'ai la chance de
faire quand même un métier
extraordinaire j'ai la chance de pouvoir
rêver et de pouvoir le lendemain presque
exécuté mon rêve et c'est vrai que
toutes ces pièces plus tard elles sont
pas vandalisés ou cassé son fret pour
l'éternité